domingo por la noche lejos de las
cámaras una entrevista entre el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron y
Georgia meloni la nueva jefa del
gobierno italiano el aumento de los
precios de la energía el apoyo Ucrania y
la gestión de los flujos migratorios han
estado en el centro de la discusión
según Roma ambos líderes expresaron su
voluntad de trabajar juntos como
europeos en países vecinos como pueblos
amigos con Italia debemos continuar todo
el trabajo iniciado triunfar juntos con
diálogo y ambición se lo debemos a
nuestra juventud y a nuestros pueblos
nuestro primer encuentro en Roma Georgia
meloni va en esta dirección
voluntad de diálogo pero del lado
francés no se baja la guardia frente a
este gobierno italiano de extrema
derecha el primero desde 1946 Emmanuel
macon llegó el domingo por la tarde a
Roma en el marco de una conferencia de
paz el presidente francés envió un
mensaje de Esperanza sobre la guerra en
Ucrania
dependiendo de cómo se desarrollen las
cosas y cuando el pueblo ucraniano y sus
líderes decidan en los términos que
decidan la paz se luchará entre ellos y
los enemigos de hoy alrededor de una
mesa y la comunidad nacional al lado y
la comino Internacional
de la discusión en una audiencia privada
con el Papa Francisco la tercera desde
que este fue designado como sumo
pontífice se extendió a lo largo de 55
minutos precedida por el tradicional
intercambio de regalos y aunque no hubo
comunicado estando parte del encuentro
la preocupación por Ucrania trascendió
como tema central